Well into the eighties, corporate
CEOs were cigarette-smoking,
suit-wearing gentlemen who maybe
played some golf on the weekends.
The CEOs of today are not
only rich they are ripped!
And I’m not just talking about Jeff Bezos who
famously went from looking like this…to this.
I am talking about so many high-profile CEOs.
Mark Zuckerberg
Telegram executive Pavel Durov
Record executive Scooter Braun
Businessman Strauss Zelnick
who posed in purple spandex.
High-end real estate broker Jason Oppenheim.
The Wall Street Journal calls it “the
latest power move for middle-aged men:
looking like an ad for protein powder.”
So, why is there suddenly
such a focus on getting fit?
Well, when selfies and social media are the norm,
there is a greater awareness of public image.
Zuckerberg showed off his punches and kicks on
Instagram as he trained with
a professional MMA fighter.
He says he fell in love with mixed
martial arts during the pandemic.
The shift to remote work meant
people suddenly found themselves
locked indoors with a lot
more time on their hands.
While that could also mean
putting on the pandemic pounds,
those with money and a team behind them took
advantage of the time to focus on fitness.
But getting ripped is not only
the result of the pandemic.
It’s a turning of the tables of sorts.
Men used to be judged by their shoes and
their watch. So long as they were rich,
they could slack off when it came
to their physical appearance.
But that’s not really true anymore, especially
when women began to wield financial success
when the workplace doors started to open
for them in the sixties and seventies.
Female executives have long known
the importance of appearance – and
that includes staying physically fit.
And now, the beauty standard has fallen on men.
It’s almost unacceptable to be fat and flabby.
When Elon Musk soaked up the sun
on a friend’s yacht in the summer,
he got a lot of body shaming
for the way he looked.
Some fun in the Mykonos sun may have been a
rarity for the richest person in the world.
His lack of a tan could mean he’s
hard at work inside Tesla’s factories.
By the way, you may recall Musk took a
jab at Bill Gates by tweeting a photo
of the Microsoft founder side by
side with the pregnant man emoji.
Musk acknowledged on the podcast Full
Send that he needs to exercise more.
Musk acknowledged on the podcast Full Send
that he needs to exercise more even though
he doesn’t like it. He says he’ll try
to work out for at least 20 minutes
as soon as he wakes up instead of
immediately looking at his phone.
I gotta work out and be in better shape. So.
We need you around. Thanks. I actually don’t
really like working out but I gotta do it.
He says he’ll try to work out for at
least 20 minutes as soon as he wakes
up instead of immediately looking at his phone.
There’s perhaps another deeper reason for CEOs to
go from looking like nerds to
looking like Thor these days.
Exercise also releases brain
chemicals that improve your memory,
concentration, and mental sharpness.
Giving you a major advantage in the workplace.
In the way pro athletes prepare for competition,
running a company is extremely competitive:
mentally and physically demanding with long
days that stretch into nights and weekends.
Musk famously worked 120 hours a week or 17 hours
a day - during his company’s most trying times.
Some CEOs believe they wouldn’t be where
they are today without staying in shape.
Despite his busy schedule running Virgin Group,
Richard Branson finds time to exercise every day.
When I wake up in the morning, I normally
go and play a very hard game of tennis,
really early, about 6 in the morning with
somebody who’s a lot better than me. A pro.
And then, I might go for a quick kite surf.
I live on an island so I’m lucky. I’ll then
go into the gym with somebody, maybe
do 40 minutes of weightlifting one day.
And then, the next day, I will
run or ride bikes or whatever.
The 72-year-old swears by the
fact that fitness has been the
key to his success, saying in an interview:
“I definitely can achieve twice
as much in a day by keeping fit.”
Mark Cuban’s proudest exercise moment is
when he bench-pressed 300 pounds and also,
when the Dallas Mavericks owner dunked a
basketball for the first time at the age of 37.
Apparently, a CEO’s fitness level
DOES affect the bottom line.
In a decade-long study of 1,500 executives,
the University of Cologne found in 2015
that a CEO’s physical fitness was associated
with higher firm profitability and higher
merger and acquisition announcement returns.
So, a healthy leader makes the company more money
- for both themselves and for their shareholders.
Allowing the wealthy CEO to splurge on yachts
- this one is reportedly Bezos’ – property,
and investing in their own health even more.
Being healthy so you feel better and perform
your best should be top of mind for everyone,
not only those with billions of dollars.
Getting good sleep is incredibly
important for your health.
That’s why I trust Magnesium
Breakthrough by BiOptimizers.
Ever since I’ve been taking
Magnesium Breakthrough since January, my
sleep has gotten significantly better.
I find I’m more relaxed and less
stressed throughout the day which
is really helpful because making these
videos demands a lot of my attention.
What makes magnesium breakthrough stand out
is that there are no synthetic ingredients.
All of the ingredients are naturally derived.
When you get all seven critical forms of
magnesium as you do with Magnesium Breakthrough,
your body gets a serious upgrade so you
can feel better throughout your day.
If you head to magnesiumbreakthrough.com/newsthink
you’ll save an extra 10%.
My custom link is in my
description and pinned comment.
And don’t forget to use my promo
code: NEWSTHINK10 at checkout.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.